hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa
we're both not at our best right now no
you're not we're hanging out so we're
like well we just watched some trailers
right now I'm a little sick she has no
makeup no we're really good this is what
you call preparation we're really ready
to go we're gonna rock this one today
dedication this is dedication wide open
you can't just work when you're feeling
good oh no it when Karen not feeling
good do you think when Kobe became a
legend he just [ __ ] was like oh a few
a little sick today now comparing
ourselves to Kobe Bryant is the same
exact thing this takes real athletic
skills
that's it pull up what we do they were
exercising our brain okay yeah very
early two minutes sir so we're gonna
watch an honest trailer today an honest
trailer for The Lion King I don't know
what an honest trailer is she doesn't
know what the honest trailers are um but
the Lion King is like my favorite thing
in the universe at all time so I'm
really excited I didn't know that's what
we were watching well if you haven't you
if you haven't seen our trailer I don't
want to tell anything about it I just
want you to watch it
before they was frozen relive the peak
of Disney animation
followed immediately by its downfall Oh
The Lion King revisit the original tale
the royal heir whose parents died
prompting them to run away from their
teammates dancing a song about letting
go of their worry while things fall
apart baekho in return the sweetest evil
Grizz I knew there was a reason I liked
that movie journey to Pride Rock and
animal kingdom with some incredibly
generous boarders everything the light
touches is our kingdom and its own
version of New Jersey what about that
shadowy place let's never go this where
all of its African animals talk like
they're British good morning sir
ah no que pasa Jewish moms duh
where you from gangster No
Oh see na
witness the birth of Lion King Simba and
obnoxious know-it-all who rubs his
privilege in everyone's face watches
Simba's life of leisure is shattered by
his evil uncle a line who was either
named scar by coincidence already got
struck with a really mean nickname get
ready for a g-rated movie filled with
domestic abuse ha ha a child raised by a
same-sex couple not that there's a
problem at and the most dramatic death
of a parent since Pammy's mom got shot
in the face worse cuz they don't show up
any long after Oh kunam Matata ha ha ha
so that grows and go and experience the
best music of any Disney musical ever
with unforgettable songs like they'll be
careful what you wish for so the
plotting evil stuff song so prepare
because I am the bad guy be prepared for
the catchy song to distract kids from
the horrific death I just saw an African
catchphrase the slow jam
we are generally gonna
yeah but now it's time to
and the song that fools us into thinking
these animals live in harmony
refined
a story why in Jabar bird sebastian ha
ha I'm Skippy ed Edd and Eddy do the
eyes dad Vader and Kimba the White Lion
seriously look it up The Lion King wait
if Mufasa and scar the only male lions
in the pride the NAS dad is probably oh
no oh oh I just wait for you to click
that subscribe button if you do you'll
surely feel the love tonight
yes that's what honest trailers are I
like it can we do warp you know when I
was little in the beginning of circle of
life when the song comes on I legitimate
ly used to think that it said pink
pajamas penguins on the bottom people
genna's penguins on the bud pick the
gems pain was on the bottom so my aunt
legitimately made me penguin pants pink
penguin pants huh how adorable
your grandma sounds cool I would have
liked to meet your grandma huh oh my
love my grandma I would love your
grandma and your ride you guys would
have fun those were eggs that we're
making I'm gonna go turn it down yeah
your aunt sounds really cool
I would have liked me nor does she look
like you no really no machiya lives down
here actually in San Diego oh really and
the rest of my family really yeah so uh
how old is she
don't just I'm curious that's all
I just want to know how old is she eat
my cousin how's your cousin wait which
is 20 something see you take it back
she's 23
what was she like we treated each other
growing up
yeah she's blond all right I like like
strawberry blonde all right
yeah and she's one of my best friends
now now that we've grown up and gotten
over each other's bad selves I don't
know what she looks like yet but I know
a threesome between the three of us
would be really hot no no you want to do
it not even now I want something really
good or now like my child what well not
my child I currently have you what you
can have
you can give birth to my child stop yeah
okay just follow your head I'm I don't
think I'm ahead yeah no one told us to
watches I just really wanted to watch it
on this trailer now I know what they are
yeah you know it's funny about honest
trailers is they [ __ ] like can take
great movies that you thought were
perfect bingo hmm never thought about
that before you know what I realized
today this was just a thought that I had
when I was like waking up out of my
sleep Hercules
let me let me let me restart yeah
because you were going for a while Ariel
is the sub is the daughter of Trident
who is the son of Poseidon whose
brothers with Zeus who had Hercules
Hercules and Ariel are cousins
ah that's my first out of the day Wow
yep
Wow so you like nothing to do when you
wake up I know my mind is just
constantly on Disney rerun stuff okay
well guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe that would be great
and alyssa has her own channel Alyssa be
out of her [ __ ] mind
right here let's go well you exerting
that much energy right now and does not
feel good for me can you guess what time
of the video it is what can you guess
what we do know shout out it I guess
it's super so long dude gosh good myself
whatever man around you
well did you should you should be
grateful for me alright you see my penis
it is huge
I haven't no and I won't it was a huge
ding-a-ling what do you mean you think
things why wouldn't you ever look in my
penis how many times I've offered just
let you see it I don't even you have to
touch it you can just I always have
these kinds of talks whenever I like
watch it kids trigger I understand I
never take any consideration at all that
children might be watching whatever I
saw showgirls when I was six he wasn't a
comedy but still that's worse than any
comedy I'd ended up fine
now I got a solid career watching
trailers Arturo Hernandez hey Ryan
love your videos can I get a shout out
please Arturo yes you may
you know I knew a guy named Arturo once
ie I don't know exactly who Arturo was
you saw you didn't know all I know is I
know I don't even know of a face I just
so you knew of this person there's a big
difference there yeah like I know that I
know someone I knew someone once who is
Archer I just can't member who he was or
what he looked like I just remember
thinking Arturo's a really interesting
name ghosts of the past ghosts of
Christmas past
was it blown Christmas this happened
last Christmas
Arturo Hernandez happened last Christmas
he found me and now he's commenting me
anywhere a churro dude I love your
videos too
don't ask me how I got ahold of your
videos but I'm banging your mom I'm
banging your mom and she lets me see the
family videos David or me res that was
really hesitant you should do it again
dick Devon Ramirez he said on the
Transformers video I think you were in
it nice video man and the girl on the
left is really pretty that was you
you're a lucky dude and please give me a
shout-out I subbed and I love your
videos I would be so happy if you gave
me a shout-out Devon I'm giving you a
[ __ ] shout-out you look young I'm
giving you an effing shout out there we
go really is freaking shout out yes ah
you see Devon there comes a point in
your life when you're gonna go hey I can
just edit it do another take but I don't
believe in doing that it's Jam if it
gets set out of my mouth like that
wasn't a proper sentence but I'm gonna
keep it anyway not cuz I'm a lazy editor
you just you gotta keep it raw that's
the key Devon that's the key
Ronis like our faces like our faces I
say don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about what do you mean our faces
you're not wearing makeup I'm not
wearing makeup Oh
so ref Kaname okay there was a call back
to a previous thing someone that you
said right right I got it it was
hilarious
Jonathan Seraphin he said shout out and
he has a picture of a wolf howling or
something yeah that's Jonathan he
becomes a werewolf and I how cool is
that only window know in movies out days
they don't need a full moon to become a
werewolf but I want to become a full
wolf on a half moon than a werewolf on a
full moon you know this got me realizing
Twilight really redefined vampires and
werewolves forever like you really
you've made a mark in its turd cuz I'm
pretty sure Twilight like vampires don't
Sparkle no that's what I mean is like
from now on all vampires should Sparkle
they they raise the bar and they lowered
the bar I'm sorry I don't agree I love
the book John agree
wait the years don't really forth before
the movie Twilight franchise is one of
the greatest things of all time no you
don't know her time we have werewolves
no one will ever be able to beat Jacob
black hmm now because he is just it for
her lungs deep well the difference is
you're not just a wolf you're like a 10
foot tall giant ass wolf that like can
destroy everything in its path but
that's what major redefining and a
game-changer but I want to be a regular
wolf because you could get away with so
much more and be unseen in the shadows
instead of be like walking out the door
and being 10 feet solid maybe would be
like one yeah but Jacob black and turn
into a werewolf at any moment that's not
how it works
yeah so it's nice Jonathan back me up
here man you got the wolf picture thing
going on tell me tell me right now that
Jacob black is the best thing to happen
to werewolves everybody you're 15 I love
Izzy it takes me seriously
no it's books wrong with that badass